all right 26 on your Finally Friday
what's cool at school how about a Rancho
High School grad elected as co-president
of the student body at Harvard
on the student leadership campaign Trail
John Cook and eventual co-president
shikohirobayashi said their main
priority would be student access to
Mental Health Resources students are
feeling burnt out students feeling a lot
of anxiety like with the pressure of
jobs the pressure of college to make
sure that any student who needs mental
health resources can get it in a very
timely manner the government major says
he wouldn't be where he is today without
his own support network I saw a
character coming into college and my mom
sentence and it was like in college you
can have like two of the following three
things you could have sleep good grades
or a social life you can pick two of
those and several teachers from Rancho
especially love to give a shout out to
Mr Route 10 by apus history teacher Mr
DeSilva uh he's actually an assemblyman
in the Nevada assembly now he also
mentioned Deborah Hogue who coached
Ranchos Varsity quiz team yeah it turns
out that John and I met during an online
pandemic edition of the Vegas PBS show
which U.S president appeared before
Congress and called for a declaration of
war against Germany Woodrow Wilson
yes and even though he has lofty goals I
want to be a criminal defensive attorney
primarily and then after that I want to
either enter the Judiciary as a judge or
like enter politics and public service
back home in Vegas but if anybody can do
it it's John Cook got a bright future
you know we always want to know what's
cool at school if you got something let
us know cool it's cool under the
Community tab of 8newsnow.com or just
email cool at school at 8newsnow.com